FRIDAY.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES.
BELL BOARD YES.
BRADFORD CARRY IT ALL
[inaudible]
JANE.
DODD.
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GLAZER GROVE HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
HILL.
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MONEY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RAIL NIELSEN PAN.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH.
RUBIO SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER Y. CASKEY WIENER WILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SECRETARY A QUORUM IS PRESENT
MEMBERS WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK
THIS WEEK.
BOTH TO THE PRO TEN STAFF ALL
YOUR TEAM AS WELL AS A TEAM UP
HERE AT THE FRONT DESK
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
BILLS HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA ASK ALL
MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO PLEASE
RISE ALONG WITH OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL.
WE'LL BE LETTING PRAYER THIS
MORNING BUYER CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR MOREAU.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE AGAIN.
GOD OF MERCY AND COMPASSION.
AS WE REMEMBER AND GRATITUDE TO
THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES
IN THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM.
WE PRAY FOR OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN
MILITARY SERVICE.
MAY THEY SERVE WITH HONOR
DIGNITY AND DEVOTION TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO ARE
IMPERILED BY INJUSTICE.
LUCK WITH LOVE AND ALL THOSE WHO
WAITS FOR THE SAFE RETURN OF
THEIR LOVED ONES.
AND GRANT THEM PEACE OF MIND AND
HEART.
MAY ALL OF US CONTINUE TO GROW
AND UNDERSTANDING OF OURSELVES
AS ONE HUMAN FAMILY.
SO THAT WE CAN LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DAY.
WHEN WARS AND CONFLICTS ARE NO
LONGER NECESSARY?
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
LET'S PLAYS READY AGAIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
YEAH. FOR AS ONE NATION UNDER
GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
MEMBERS.
ADVANCING THE PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE STATE
SENATE WE WANT TO WELCOME
STUDENTS IN THE GALLERY FROM THE
YUCAIPA YOUTH ADVISORY COMMITTEE
RESIDING IN SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY THREE LET'S GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE PLEASE.
SENATORS WERE NOT IN THE MOOD
MOVING FORWARD IN OUR DAILY FILE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES.
YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S GONNA BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE IN OUR MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATORS WITHOUT OBJECTION
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE THIRTY
THREE POINT.
ONE JOINT RULES TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT POINT ONE IN TWENTY
NINE AS THEY RELATE TO THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON AB.
SEVENTY FOUR WILL BE SUSPENDED.
SENATORS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR MAY
TWENTIETH THROUGH THE TWENTY
FOURTH. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WILL BE APPROVED IN CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE UNDER
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SECOND READING FILE.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY FOUR
SENATE BILL TWO INCIDENTAL SOME.
FORTY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SECRETARY THE SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
SENATORS WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
FAIRLY QUICK SESSION WE DO HAVE
SOME RESOLUTIONS IN FRONT OF US.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE UNDER SENATE THIRD
READING.
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN FIRST FILE ITEM
SIXTY SEVEN SENIOR COPIER ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT SHE IS
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY BY
SENATOR CAFIERO RELATIVE TO
LATINA ACTION DAY.
HAPPY FRIDAY CENTER COPY YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS 2% SR FORTY WHICH
RECOGNIZES MAY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS LATINA ACTION DAY.
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF OUR STATE
IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY LATINOS HAVE
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND
POPULATION.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
AND TWO THOUSAND THIRTY THE
STATE'S POPULATION WILL CREATE
INCREASED BY THREE POINT SIX
MILLION LATINOS.
WE ARE A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND FUTURE
OVER THE YEARS LATINOS HAVE
SHOWCASE THEIR GREAT STRENGTH
AND TALENT IN EVERY DISCIPLINE
AND FIELD.
INCLUDING THE SCIENCE ART AND
POLITICS IT IS GREAT FEMALE
LEADERS LIKE ELEANOR CHIRLA THE
LOTUS WENT THAT JOAN BAEZ ISABEL
ALLENDE FRIDA KAHLO AND SON YES
SO TO MY YOUR WEB INSPIRED
LATINA ACTION DAY.
EVERY YEAR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
LIKE THE UNITS FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA CONVENE IN SACRAMENTO
FOR LIKE THE IN ACTION DAY.
AN ANNUAL PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES
CONFERENCE ORGANIZED BY THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION HOPE. FOR
THE SPANISH ORGANIZE FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY. FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS THIS ONE DAY
CONFERENCE HAS CREATED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR DIALOGUE BETWEEN
CORPORATE.
COMMUNITY AND ELECTED LATINA
OFFICIALS TO DISCUSS CURRENT
ISSUES AND POLICIES WHICH AFFECT
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN OF COLOR.
LIKEWISE THIS CONFERENCE ALSO
CREATES A SPACE FOR YOUNG LATINO
LEADERS THE GAME FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE IN ADVOCACY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO SPEAK. TO
DIFFERENT REPRESENTATIVES AND
VOICE OUR CONCERNS.
IT IS IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS OF OUR WOMEN OF COLOR TO
ENABLE FUTURE GENERATIONS TO
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW IN THEIR
FOOTSTEPS AND TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME AND
CELEBRATING LATINA ACTION DAY
FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BY BATES.
BY BILL.
AYE BURGESS [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M RAIL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
I LIKE KELSEY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK BY.
THIS IS SIX THIRTY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I GROVE [inaudible]
HUESO.
THIS IS A KERRY CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
GROWTH [inaudible]
HUESO.
MEMBERS SIZE THIRTY SIX KNOWS
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
SENATORS.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE. TO FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX CENTER JONES
IS PREPARED TO TAKE UP WAY BACK
IN THE FREEZER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ.
THE KICKER RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO
BY SENATOR JONES RELATIVE TO
MOTORCYCLE AWARENESS MONTH.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR JONES OF
FORESHORE SIR MORNING MR
PRESIDENT ALREADY THIS MORNING
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB JUST
ONE LET YOU KNOW THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE WENT BACKWARDS IN THE
FILE.
AB COLLEAGUES SENATORS S. C. R.
FIFTY TWO DESIGNATES THE MONTH
OF MAY. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
MOTORCYCLE AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS A SAFE AND LAW ABIDING
MOTORCYCLE RIDER AN ENTHUSIAST I
SUPPORT.
MOTORCYCLISTS RIGHTS AND SAFETY.
MOTORCYCLES ACCOUNT FOR LESS
THAN 5% OF REGISTERED VEHICLES
IN THE UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER THEY PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF
TASK TRANSPORTATION.
THE USES FEWER RESOURCES.
CAUSES LESS WEAR AND TEAR ON THE
PUBLIC ROADWAYS AND INCREASES
AVAILABLE PARKING SPOTS.
LAST WEEKEND I PARTICIPATED IN
MY LOCAL MAY RIDE.
ALONG WITH THOUSANDS OF LOCAL
WRITERS IN MY DISTRICT TO
SUPPORT OUR TROOPS AND RAISE
MONEY FOR THE ARMED SERVICES
YMCA.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE WAY IN
TRAINING AND SAFETY FOR MORE
CYCLISTS.
THIS RESOLUTION COMMEMORATES THE
MANY EFFORTS MADE BY VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS TO KEEP WRITER
SAFE.
AS YOU ALL DRIVE AROUND OUR
GREAT STATE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR MOTORCYCLES.
AND TAKE EXTRA PRECAUTIONS TO
KEEP OUR WRITERS SAFE AS
CALTRANS SAYS.
SHARE THE ROAD.
LOOK TWICE FOR MOTORCYCLISTS.
FURTHERMORE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
GET OUT THERE AND LEARN TO RIDE
A MOTORCYCLE.
THERE IS NO BETTER FEELING.
I WILL EVEN TAKE YOU OUT RIDING.
IN THE BEAUTIFUL THIRTY EIGHT
THE SENATE DISTRICT OR FOR THAT
MATTER ANY PART OF THE STATE.
WITH FUN.
CURVY.
CURVY ROADS.
TYPE S. TURNS WHY DID SWEEPING
CHICANES AND OPENS STRAIGHT
AWAYS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER JONES
AND ALWAYS WEAR YOUR HELMET AS
WELL.
IN ORDER TO RAZA.
YES THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR --
THIS IS PROBABLY NOT SOMETHING
THAT MOST PEOPLE WOULD THINK I
WOULD STAND UP AND SPEAK ON BUT
I HAVE MADE MANY MEMBERS I DO
NOT RIDE -- BUT I HAVE MANY
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY MY SISTER
LIVES MY NIECES MY NEPHEWS IN
LAWS I'M SURROUNDED BY THE BIKES
BEAUTIFUL BIKES EVERY TIME I GO
TO FRESNO -- AND I'M JUST WANT
TO SPEAK ON THEIR BEHALF OF NOT
ONLY BEING AWARE OF THEM AS THEY
DRIVE GIVE THEM THE COURTESY
THAT THEY DESERVE -- BUT ALSO TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY COME FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
THERE IS NO ONE OF DEMOGRAPHIC
THERE'S NO ONE DESCRIPTION OUR
IDENTITY THEY COME FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE AND SO I JUST WANT
TO JUMP IN AND SAY NOT ONLY
SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION -- BUT TO
EXPLAIN THE DIVERSITY OF THOSE --
MOTORCYCLE RIDERS BIKERS
WHATEVER OTHER TERM WE USE AND
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR DRAWS -- ENJOY THE
DODGERS GAME ON MONDAY AND GO
GIANTS -- MEMBERS WE THANK TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE ARE.
ANY ADDITIONAL.
IT IS OUR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
HEARING SEE NINE CENTER JONES
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
THINK YES CENTER DRAWS -- FOR
HER -- VERY APPROPRIATE COMMENTS
AND POINTING OUT SOME.
THINGS ABOUT MORE CYCLE SAFETY
THAT I'M TO COLLECTED TO TO THIS
POINT OUT AS WELL AND AND AND
SHE IS ONE OF PERCENT CORRECT IN
FACT -- CURRENTLY IN THE UNITED
STATES THE NUMBER OF FEMALE
WRITERS IS ON THE RISE -- ALMOST
UP 220% -- SEVERAL FAMOUS FEMALE
RACERS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD ALSO -- ON THE
RISE AS WELL SO EVEN A AND I
FORGET HER NAME NOW BUT A A
WOMAN THAT'S A MOTORCYCLE DRAG
RACER.
SO -- WHICH IS A VERY DANGEROUS
SPORT BUT IS FUND THAT HAVE THEM
INVOLVED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS I ASK YOU A VOTE.
THE SYNERGEN SPECIFIC TRICKING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL AYE
BURGESS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
I MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GALGIANI
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROWTH RUBIO [inaudible]
I SEND IT SENATORS SIZE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
ADVANCE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IF THERE'S ANY ITEM
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS THAT
THE SENATE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE MADAM PRO TEM IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS THE DESK IS CLEAR
MR PRESIDENT THANKS SO MUCH -- I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
AN INCREDIBLY PRODUCTIVE.
WEEK AS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT
THAT THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T.
UNDERSTAND THE NEXUS BETWEEN
APPRECIATION FOR MOTORCYCLES AND
THE GIANTS AND THE DODGERS BUT
WE WILL FORGIVE HIM THAT --
UNLESS I'M MISSING SOMETHING --
BUT I WANTED TO JUST WISH MY
COLLEAGUES A REALLY.
GIVEN THE PRODUCTIVE NATURE OF
THIS WEEK A REALLY WONDERFUL
WEEKEND AT HOME AND CERTAINLY AS
WE MOVE INTO MEMORIAL DAY THE
PRE APPRECIATION FOR OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS.
AND THOSE THAT HAVE DEFENDED OUR
COUNTRY -- THAT WE PAY THE
PROPER RESPECT AND AND DO THAT
ON MONDAY AND I WILL SEE YOU ALL
ON TUESDAY.
OF TUESDAY AT NOON -- WE WILL
RECONVENE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM GREAT
WORK DO YOU AND YOUR TEAM AS
WELL THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACE.
WE'LL RECONVENE [inaudible]
TUESDAY [inaudible]
AT NOON.
THANK YOU MEMBERS